after a year in the top job at the SPD
and Riaan Alice says she's standing down
because she feels she can't go on
discussions in the Parliamentary Group
and feedback from the party have shown
that I no longer have the necessary
support to carry out my duties on Monday
I will therefore resign as chair of the
SPD and on Tuesday I will resign as
chair of the SPD parliamentary group
analysis resignation follows her party's
dismal performance in last month's
European elections its worst ever
showing at the polls the results that we
have so far are extremely disappointing
for the SPD everyone knows that the
surveys regarding our party have not
been good in the last few weeks our task
was to try and work our way out of these
poor survey results sadly despite all
our work we didn't manage to swing
things around the SPD was once a big
tent party but years of playing second
fiddle in Chancellor Angela Merkel's
governments have left the Social
Democrats struggling to stay relevant
new polling puts the SPD at just 12% a
distant third behind the greens and
conservatives Merkel's coalition has
found it difficult to make headway since
it's painful formation after the 2017
German election Merkel wants to see out
her final term until 2021 we will
continue the government's work with all
seriousness we will above all do so with
a great sense of responsibility the
issues we have to solve are for Germany
and Europe and the rest of the world
with this mindset we will continue
working that's likely to prove no easy
task
especially with both the main parties
seeing their support heading away
let's get more now we are joined by GW
political correspondent Simon Young so
Simon as we saw there Andre annales due
to officially resign later today what
direction is the SPD likely to take
after her departure well Sarah that's
far from clear at this stage and the
party is of course still reeling from
this surprise announcement yesterday but
many in the party say that what's needed
is a change in policies and many feel
that that really means a stronger Social
Democrat profile ie a stronger sort of
left-wing profile and they believe that
that is the only way to stop their party
hemorrhaging supporters has been doing
in election after election but it also
depends of course on who is going to be
the new Social Democrat leader and
frankly at this point who would want
that difficult job but it'll be up to
them to decide how they can best put
across a social democrat agenda possibly
outside the current coalition government
and the big question is okay what does
this now mean for Germany because
Chancellor Merkel other conservative
leaders they are all saying that they
want to keep keep the SPD on board but
assignment is it too late could this
resignation bring down Merkel's
government well I think it could
eventually and by the way the Social
Democrat Finance Minister Olaf Schatz
just published an article of
coincidentally yesterday in which he was
saying you know 1/3 grand coalition is
not good for German democracy and you
know shouldn't be contemplated and then
frankly the left wing of the SPD never
liked the idea of this left-right
coalition with Merkel's Conservatives
that they've gone into and that Andrea
knowledge really argued for so I think
it's difficult to say how it will pan
out as I say a lot depends on who's the
new leader
the timetable at the moment looks to be
that the party will probably choose a
new leader in perhaps around September
and it'll be up to them as I say to
decide whether they think they should
get out of the coalition with Merkel if
they do that then it's very likely that
within a few months anyway there would
be new elections because the government
would fall
Simon young in Berlin thank you so where
does Germany where does the SPD go from
here for an inside look let's bring in
Annika close a leader of the Berlin
branch of the SPD's Youth Organization
they use us thank you so much for
joining us this morning was she right to
resign I think it was a consequential
step of Angela marichuy oh and they're
not as to resign because the criticism
of her was really big in the last weeks
and I think even though she offered to
have re-elections at the parliamentary
group on Tuesday I think that would have
not silenced the voices of criticism but
I think also that the pressure was
really really high on her and they was
quite unfair actually and to blame her
as a person for the results of the
European election and she actually said
when she you know announced this that
the party needs to regain the trust and
the respect for one another
did the SPD treat its leader badly I
think for some factors was it was unfair
and I think that she suffered from
criticism because she was not so popular
and she's a character which is not so
common in politics because you know
sometimes she's just really yeah a
character you know she does things that
are not really common but I think also
that politics needs some people who are
like do unexpected things or have some
comments which is I think it's nice to
have people like that but I also think
that she did do some mistakes and I
think that we need change in the
leadership but just one person it's not
gonna do the deal ultimately it was her
who persuaded the party to join Merkel's
coalition government last year a very
you know we know that your party wanted
to enter the opposition for example what
happens to the coalition now we really
don't know and we use this the youth
organization we pushed for the
affiliation of the coalition
our Party Congress in December so I
think we need to pull that forward and
do that earlier this year actually and
we need our party Congress earlier than
December we need a reelection of the
party board and we need that affiliation
of the grand coalition really soon
because honestly it's a grand coalition
if we look at supports if we look at the
results of the European election is not
a grand coalition anymore the people
expect us to do more than what we're
doing right now and I think it's just
not going we're just not gonna be able
to fulfill what we need to do with the
Conservatives what happens to the SPD
now because I mean your party is
bleeding voters not only on the German
level but also you know generally
speaking on the European level as well
and especially to the Green Party yes
that's true because the climate change
is the biggest winning topic at the
moment and I think so social democracy
was not able to push that topic as much
as we would have needed to do that and
to also make it a social question at the
climate change like how are we going to
manage it how are you going to finance
it how are we going to do it without
losing jobs or what are we going to do
with the people who are losing the jobs
how do we invest all these questions are
on the table and so social democracy
well we do we're doing coalition's and
deals with with the Conservatives who
are doing nothing but protecting the
economy even if we need huge change in
the economy so I think they are on
European level on German level we need
to do some changes we need to set in
your agenda a call for action yeah I'm
the youth party from the youth
organization of the SPD Annika Klose
thank you thank you